what's the latest update you give us on
this situation in Dover
well I know that many families will be
very concerned about some of the delays
that we've been seeing at Dover over the
last 24 48 Hours people trying to get
away for their Easter holidays I would
urge them to check their travel plans if
they're about to set off to Dover but
that the situation is improving there's
been a an acute level of pressure put on
the ferry companies and the coach
companies a 35 increase in bookings it's
obviously always a busy time of year but
the government's in close contact with
the Port Authorities and the local
resilience Forum to ensure that we start
getting people crossing the channel
quickly you talk about the increase in
people trying to make the journey but of
course it's a busy time of year and the
CEO of dogapur said the difference of
living in a post-brexit environment
means that every passport news be
checked do we need to after brexit just
get used to this happening at busy
periods no I don't think that's fair to
say this has been uh you know an adverse
effect of brexit think we've seen we've
had many years now since leaving the
European Union and there's been on the
whole very good operations and processes
the Border but what I would say is acute
times when there's a lot of pressure uh
crossing the channel whether that's uh
on the the tunnel or ferries then I
think that there's always going to be a
backup and I just urge everybody to be a
bit patient while the ferry companies
work their way through the backlog and I
this is one other story I want to ask
you about before we get onto your
announcement and three British men being
held by the Taliban now one of them is
Miles rootledge a so-called danger
tourist he returned to Afghanistan after
being previously evacuated by armed
forces from the UK
well anyone traveling to uh dangerous
parts of the world should take the
utmost caution if they are going to do
that they should always act on the
advice of the foreign office travel
advice that's sense this guy's been
violated before and I think you know if
there are risks to people's safety if
there are British citizen abroad then
the UK government is going to do
whatever it takes to ensure that they're
safe and the government is in
negotiations
um and working hard to ensure people uh
people safety is upheld so you are in
negotiation Center well we're always
well if there are problems and if there
are safety concerns uh to British
individuals who brought them the scdo
will be uh uh working actively to ensure
people are safe I want to talk about
your policy it's about child sexual
exploitation just explain what it is
that you're announcing today
well there's been uh there's been
several reports over recent years about
what I consider to be one of the biggest
scandals actually in recent years in in
our history and that is a systematic and
institutional failure
to safeguard the welfare of children
when it comes to sexual abuse and we saw
recently Professor Jay's report be
published and that makes very harrowing
reading and what I'm announcing today
and the Prime Minister will be building
on this tomorrow is a series of measures
to bring an end to this and properly
Safeguard children it's a consultation
why why is that a consultation people
have been demanding action for years
what's important to remember is that
what we're seeing in grooming gangs or
gangs of rapists is in towns and cities
around the country we're seeing a
practice evolve which has evolved which
is taking advantage of vulnerable
children and let's be honest happening
you say it's a great Scandal why are you
Consulting why do you not just take
action well we need to get the legal
Duty right we don't want unintended
consequences but what's clear is that
what we've seen is a practice whereby uh
vulnerable White English girls
um sometimes in care sometimes who are
in challenging circumstances being
pursued and raped and drugged and harmed
by gangs of British Pakistani men who've
worked in child abuse Rings or networks
we've seen institutions and state
agencies whether it's social workers
teachers the police uh turn a blind eye
to these to these signs of abuse out of
political correctness out of fear of
being called racist out of fear of being
called bigoted and as a result thousands
we're not talking in small numbers we're
talking large number thousands of
children have had their childhoods
robbed and devastated and there are many
of these perpetrators still running wild
behaving in this way and it's now down
to the authorities to track these
perpetrators down without fear or favor
relentlessly and bring them to justice
you say that the premise is going to
build on this tomorrow what else are we
expecting though well today I've
announced that we are going to introduce
a consultation on mandatory reporting
what the reports show is as I said
professionals who had duties on
safeguarding and looking after the
welfare of children saw the signs things
were reported to them uh
um concerns about abuse or rape or
exportation were disclosed to these
professionals and they didn't take any
action it's outrageous what we're
looking at is imposing a duty on anybody
or a professionals who are in working in
child safeguarding to actually report
and take action when they come into
possession of information that may raise
concern I think everyone is over the
last few years has been horrified by
some of the reports and as you say
um the fact that some of these girls
were simply not believed vulnerable
young people not being believed not
being taken seriously
um do you also accept though that
grooming gangs are not necessarily just
Pakistani so home office report in 2020
found grooming gangs most commonly white
and despite some of the high profile
cases that we described they said that
the links between ethnicity and this
form of the funding could not be proven
what I refer you to the extensive report
uh about Rotherham uh several years back
followed by the report by Louise Casey
those two reports were unflinching in
their assessment of the problem there
have been several reports since about
the predominance of certain ethnic
groups and I say British Pakistani males
who hold cultural values totally at odds
with British values who see women in a
demeaned and illegitimate way and pursue
an outdated and frankly heinous approach
in terms of the way they behave we've
got to stamp that out with criminal law
and proper safeguarding and we're only
going to do that if as a society we face
up to the facts and the truth of what's
actually going on you talk though about
Lewis Casey and a big part of this as
well is trust in the Mets right if
you're talking about child sexual abuse
in any sort of sexual abuse as well now
the case review internet police said it
was institutionally racist and
misogynistic is it fit for purpose and
your Home Secretary right what are you
going to do about it
well I've spoken at length about uh the
challenges with the met and no one's
shying away from the big challenges that
the Met faces right now no we say no
one's showing away from it the Met
Police Commissioner Rob Rowley has
refused to use the word institutionally
racist do you think he is actually not
really getting to grips with the
seriousness of what's happening I
disagree with that Sir Mark Rowley and
Dave Lynn Owens are the right people to
lead the Met now and Louise Casey
accepts that as well in her report uh
also Louise says that the vast majority
of serving police officers in the Met
are decent Law Abiding and uphold the
highest standard that's true but at the
same time we've had serving met police
officers raping and murdering women
taking selfies with dead bodies joking
about domestic violence and race making
racist comments I mean it is actually
incredible to see are you prepared to
break up the net if things don't improve
all of that is totally unacceptable and
the findings that Louise Casey makes of
the instances of misogyny racism
homophobia are all totally unacceptable
if it doesn't improve well even Louise
Casey doesn't recommend breaking up the
mess so I'm personally not uh at that
point I think what we've got to do is
raise standards of vetting and
recruitment I'm Consulting on the
dismissals power what we found is Chief
constables lack sufficient powers to
actually get rid of poor performing
officers uh absurdly and I'm if we need
a change in the law I will do that but
ultimately we've got to ensure that the
Met commissioner sticks to his
turnaround plan and is held to account
by by the mayor of London what happens
an important element here is the
governance now the PCC in this case the
labor mayor of London has a lot to
answer for because he's responsible
ultimately for performance and outcomes
by the Met
um now I want to talk to you about
immigration as well because in October
when you were talking about your policy
to deport migrants to Rwanda you said in
a speech at the Tory Party Conference I
would love to have a front page of the
telegraph with a plane taking you off to
Rwanda that's my dream it's my obsession
do you think that sounds a bit
a bit weird I guess is the phrase I'm
looking at that it's your dream it's
your obsession to see a plane take your
time listen I make no apology I care
very passionately about uh stopping the
boats just like the Prime Minister does
just like the vast majority of British
people do this is a problem of 45 000
people last year who arrived here
illegally uh without a legal basis
without permission abusing the
generosity of the British people we're
spending over six million pounds a night
on Hotel accommodation with three
billion pounds last year this cannot go
on so we can quibble about semantics but
the reality is what action are we taking
okay let's stop let's talk about action
then so will flights to Rwanda take off
by the summer
listen I uh we are making very steady
progress will they take up by this I'm
not going to give a deadline as to when
flights will take off uh we have to be
realistic okay we've had a very strong
victory in the high court at the end of
last year on Rwanda we've now introduced
legislation we want to move as quickly
as possible to relocate people from the
UK to Rwanda the sun on Sunday is
reporting you're set to announce a deal
with a Port Authority at Portland and
Dorset to Docker floating ship housing
migrants is that true
well as my as we announced earlier this
week we have uh we're going to be moving
forward with uh procuring is that true
that the deal in Portland I'm not going
to talk about private commercial
transactions in that negotiation in that
case right you can't tell me when the
flight's going to take off to Rwanda and
we've got no information about about um
whether or not these ships are going to
be actually used or any information so
if you don't mind I might not talk in
depth about Rwanda all the ships because
so far since a policy was announced
we've had zero flights taking up to
Rwanda we've got zero announcements on
the ships let's talk about things that
are actually happening now okay and we
can talk about these things when you've
successfully sent a single person to
Rwanda
let's have a look you mentioned the
small boats Graphics this is the number
of people arriving in the UK on small
boats you say that it's gone up and it
has 45
755. this is under a conservative
government and it's also partly
underused Home Secretary do you accept
that things are failing
I accept we've got an unsustainable
problem I've been very clear about that
I'm aware of the numbers do you do you
the problem is the failing the context
is important we're in the middle of a
global migration crisis the UK is not
alone with facing unprecedented numbers
of illegal arrivals you speak to the
French you speak to the U.S you speak to
other Western democracies they are all
grappling with unprecedented
responsibility of illegal migrant team
what I'm saying I mean if I could talk
finish a sentence and I might be able to
set out what we're actually doing we're
all grappling with unprecedented numbers
of people we have to take action now
that's why we've introduced a bill with
tough measures which are both firm and
humanitarian they will introduce a
deterrent so that people stop taking the
journey in the first place and important
okay and we'll talk evil people
smuggling gangs are stopped when they
actually happen none of this stuff has
actually happened yet despite the policy
being announced in April let's have a
look at hotels Asylum Seekers and
temporary accommodation you can see it's
spiking there do you take responsibility
this as Home Secretary well you want to
talk about things that have happened I
will show you some progress actually so
since December when the Prime Minister
made his announcement about our plan to
stop the boats we've struck a deal with
Albania we've now seen
um uh several hundred about 500 people
returned to Albania who came here
unlawfully we've also seen a record deal
with the French which has enhanced our
cooperation on the channel that's a
large part of the solution and we're now
about to procure and roll out bespoke
accommodation for Asylum Seekers so we
can start taking people out of hotels
and moving in them into more affordable
and appropriate accommodation so you
talked there about the successes
um and that as you say is partly because
of the returns agreement you struck with
albanians why aren't you talking about
things like return agreements rather
than talking about things like Rwanda
things like Hotel barges or barges for
migrants that frankly you know I just I
forgive my skepticism but they're not
happening are they
well I mean I really disagree with your
assumption I mean we're announcing these
measures because we've been working
intensively over the last few months to
arrange
um agreements Provisions these are large
complex projects that we have to
deliver you can't just announce them and
they happen overnight and that's not the
real world the real world in the real
world and working government you have to
take things step by step you have to
overcome legal procedural planning
challenges we need to we have made
announcement a pretty pivotal and
landmark announcement this week about
several sites that we have identified
around the country which we believe are
appropriate for a housing accommodate
housing Asylum Seekers and we plan to
start moving Asylum Seekers into those
sites very soon if an asylum Seeker
enters the UK immediately illegally
sorry so if an asylum Seeker enters the
UK illegally and then admits that they
made a mistake should they allow be
allowed to come back six days later I
don't think
um that get paying a people Smuggler
thousands of pounds
risking your life in a flimsy dinghy
with a thin piece of polystyrene as a
life jacket traveling at 2AM at night in
freezing cold conditions is a mistake
and I think anyone who takes the journey
is breaking the law anyone who procures
that Journey offers it or facilitates it
is breaking the law anyone who does that
is making a deliberate decision to come
to the UK illegally you don't do that by
mistake and that's why we need a robust
legal framework to ensure that anyone
who does come from a safe country
remember they're coming from a safe
country where they could claim Asylum
there is no good reason as to why they
should be taking that treacherous
Journey
people smuggling gangs to come to the UK
on a flimsy dinghy the reason I ask the
question is that you resigned of course
for committing a national security
breach for committing a security breach
and for breaking ministerial rules then
came back into the same job six days
later she does not think the rules apply
to you
uh well to correct you I didn't commit a
national security breach uh I set out in
full the circumstances of an email that
I sent to a colleague about an issue
which was uh pretty much open government
policy there was no National Security
element so please do correct your your
statement on that uh what I'm saying is
here we need to ensure that there is a
firm and robust legal framework by
whereby if you arrive in the UK
illegally you'll be determining robust
framework around the minister you'll be
detailed you did commit a security
breach you'll be detained and thereafter
swiftly removed that's what the British
people want us to do they want us to
stop the boats we need a deterrent we
need people to stop making that journey
in the first place we need to stop
seeing 45
000 people arriving here illegally we
need to stop housing 45 000 people in
hotels around towns and cities in the UK
that's when we'll be able to stop those
and that's why the prime ministers made
it one of his five key pledges because
he knows the vast majority of British
people care passionately okay we'll look
at the figures uh in next time you're on
the program and see there's been an
improvement I just want to talk a bit
about you and what you stand for because
when you ran for the party leadership
you wrote an article in Express to
launch your campaign and you said we
need to deliver rapid and large tax cuts
how do you feel being part of a
government where taxes are due to you
know potentially reach their highest
levels since the Second World War
I'm a low tax conservative and I
and I know that the prime minister is as
well and everybody in the cabinet is and
the products is going up then well we've
had unprecedented shocks to our economy
over recent years whether that's the
impacts of the pandemic uh inflation
caused by a global energy Supply
challenge because of the war in Ukraine
those have required flexibility for your
part of our Economic Policy you're
comfortable with it wholeheartedly
supportive of the government's measured
and balanced approach we want to you
come back to our current but of course
we need to get public spending under
control we need to uh you need to get
the debt down we need to grow the
economy and we need to halve inflation
those are parts of the prime minister's
plan okay
now if I may you're quite divisive I
think that's probably you know no sort
of secret you become the face of a
government's policy on migration that
some people find you know immeasurably
cruel you obviously believe in it do you
relish the fight or was it taking a bit
of a personal toll on you
well I see my role as Home Secretary as
um getting results ultimately taking
action for the British people I see
myself as telling the truth for the
British people to the British people I
see myself as being a voice for the
law-abiding patriotic often silent
majority I see myself being heavily
informed by the people in my
constituency in pharah who just want us
to stop the boats although it is fair to
say labor currently six points ahead on
immigration who want us to see Common
Sense policing who want to keep the
British people safe that's my objective
as Home Secretary and you know if the
BBC or you know various celebrities are
offended then so be it you talk about
various celebrities your husband did an
interview recently where he spoke out
about Gary lineker's tweet where he
compared the rhetoric around small boats
uh to that of 1930s Germany your husband
said that legitimized some of the abuse
that you faced do you think it's right
that he's still presenting much today
listen it's not for me to decide uh who
the programming schedule for the BBC uh
you know I I've spoken about the issue
uh with Gary lineker what I think is
important what I think the majority of
people really care about is the action
we're taking so the bill that we've
introduced will make clear that if you
arrive here illegally you'll be detained
and swiftly removed I'm very optimistic
about the passage of that bill we've
just had it go through several stages in
the Commons recently we're ongoing with
our process we've just announced new
sites for accommodation Asylum Seekers
we're making progress on Amazon on our
Asylum backlog we've seen several
thousand of cases being made and
increase productivity that's an
important element of our plan we've
reached a record deal with France a
returns agreement with Albania I think
we're making tangible process in a short
period of time but ultimately yes you'll
judge us on our record